shooting with a lot of confidence
Troy Brown all over pool
pool tripped up
[Applause]
well with a 27 point lead eight minutes
to go blowout material do you have any
more childhood nicknames we can discuss
tonight
this guy got his own Twitter handle now
the streets are talking you have
impacted again
my dad won't even come to the phone now
he felt so disrespected
what's the name Mike again what's the
name
stop it
I'm not gonna say it and we didn't just
disrespect Bill Van Gundy absolutely not
the legend he just shows a wonderful
father you're not in charge of that how
he feels that's true that's a good point
he doesn't even know like if you said
you're trending on Twitter my dad would
be like what are you talking about
a sweet move from Lonnie Walker